the family of a California grandmother
says the government is standing in the
way of her life saving cancer treatment
Helen who wins doctors say she will die
without a stem-cell transplant her
sister is in Vietnam and she's a perfect
match but the US consulate there so far
has refused to give her a temporary visa
kawin is now in intensive care at the UC
Irvine Medical Center Carter Evans spoke
with her daughters about their
frustrations they have with her family
by her bedside Helen wen is trying to
beat leukemia the 61 year old was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of the
disease in February how long does she
have
we're taking it day by day
every day with her is a gift right now
Yvonne Marie and her sister Sharon Adams
say their mom's only hope is a stem cell
transplant ideally she needs a rare 100%
match and she got it yes and with a
hundred percent match or a possibility
of it being a successful transplant is
very high
doctors say Helens sister Thuy knew in
is a perfect donor she lives in Vietnam
which no one expected to be a problem
doctors wrote letters urging the US
consulate to grant knew in an emergency
medical visa saying time is of the
essence so everything is lined up
everything except for the visa part new
ins visa application has now been denied
four times State Department spokesman
Heather nowart told CBS News stories
like this always strike me at the heart
but since records are confidential she
was unable to discuss specific visa
cases why was she denied they're afraid
that she would overextend her visa and
stay in the US illegally the family
emigrated to the u.s. in 1991 under a
program for former officers in the South
Vietnamese military helen wins husband
VN fought alongside american forces
during the vietnam war they are all US
citizens we never thought of ourself as
immigrants because this is our home
country this is all the country that we
know I feel a little bit heartbroken
because my own government is the one
prevented this whole thing from taking
place harvesting doin's stem cells in
Vietnam and shipping them to the US is
not a good option says CBS News medical
contributor and cancer specialist dr.
David agus no I don't know of a case
where they've done transplants where the
patient the donor are on different
continents there has been people that
has been you know suggesting to us hey
why don't you go to Canada or why
doesn't she go to Vietnam and get this
done but you think if your own country's
not gonna take care of you why would
another country god what in the meantime
Yvonne and Sharron are encouraging their
mom to try to hold on a little longer
while they try to cut through the red
tape I think it's a flaw in the visa
system the visa process and it needs to
change and it's time that we make that
change for CBS this morning Carter Evans
Irvine California hopefully after that
story somebody will figure something
expedite Ben if you it doesn't make any
sense thank you very much